today on the matt walsh show a school
district uses a picture of children
sledding without masks on as an excuse
to keep schools closed we'll talk about
that also
five headlines including governor cuomo
deflecting blame for his nursing home
scandal and
more big ufo news out of the pentagon
and our daily cancellation will cancel a
famous male youtuber
for the crime of appropriation in this
case uh he is
appropriating pregnancy so we gotta
cancel him for that
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
now one of the best win wins that you
can ask for right now
is when you can support a company that
provides you a valuable service
and supports your values in return
and that's charity mobile charity mobile
all the way that is one company that
fits the description charity mobile the
pro-life phone company
and the reason the pro-life phone
company is that five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice and
you get a lot of other perks as well
that's the that's the pro-life piece of
it and that's and that's it's not just a
piece that's what the company is all
about
uh when you when you support charity
mobile you're helping you're helping to
build a culture of life in america
um and in a in a in a profound way
because this is
one thing that we need to do in this
culture is to find companies
uh businesses that support our values
and to support them
so that part is great also it's a great
service
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping there's no
contract there's no termination fees
there's no risk with a 30 day guarantee
so you might as well give charity mobile
a shot you got nothing to lose nothing
to risk
live customer service based right here
in the usa and that's really important
as well
plus you get free usage alerts you get a
free app to monitor your usage
and pay your bill and a lot more all of
this while again and plus the nationwide
service on america's largest the most
reliable
4g lte network all of that while again
supporting a pro-life
company if you want to be a part of this
and you do call them at
1-877-474-3662 that's 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
so a few weeks ago we discussed how an
epidemic of child suicides in the las
vegas area had pushed
that school system to accelerate its
reopening
now we have a similar story this time
out of san francisco as the daily wire
reports quote an alarming number of san
francisco students have committed
suicide as a result of the prolonged
coronavirus lockdowns according to a
lawsuit filed by the city
against the school district on thursday
the associate associated
press reported that the lawsuit filed by
san francisco city attorney dennis
herrera includes quote
alarming testimony from hospitals in the
bay area doctors and parents on the
emotional and mental harms
of extended distance learning then we
hear from a parent
allison arif the mother of a 15 year old
daughter is quoted in the lawsuit as
saying she found her daughter
quote curled up in a fetal position
crying next to her laptop at 11 a.m
that she often crimes cries during the
day reef added that her daughter is
frustrated and losing faith not just in
the school district
but in the world this is an issue that
we've
been tracking on this show for months
now it's not confined to
las vegas and san francisco it's
nationwide in fact there was one story
out of texas a 12 year old boy
was found hanging his his nine-year-old
sister found him
hanging only a few days before his 13th
birthday his father
says that the child was quote sad and
lonely
and was driven to this point because of
the lockdowns
and it's just unthinkable
by the way this tragedy with the with
the with with the child with the 12 year
old boy
happened in april april
in april after just a month or two kids
were already at this point
now you tackle another nine ten months
on top of that
yet many schools are finding any reason
desperately searching for any reason to
stay closed
so listen to the latest here this this
is almost hard to believe
a mother in new jersey was was angry as
many parents are
that schools in the in her area were
refusing to reopen so she sent many
messages to the superintendent
expressing her frustration
this prompted the assistant
superintendent to respond finally with
an email
in the email he gives his reasons for
keeping
the schools closed no matter the
psychological effects that it's having
on the kids
and he actually places the blame
partially on the mother herself
and by extension on her kids he writes
quote this is part of the email he says
for instance we know that parents and
students are not following the same cdc
guidelines that you continue to share
with us
that detail the importance of social
distancing and mask wearing
case in point we were provided a number
of photos that illustrate the precise
reason our school community
remains in phase one as you can see from
the attached photos
you and four other adults appear in
close proximity without a mask
further the school the photo illustrates
16 children all in close proximity
without masks
bottom line we will not subject our
school community to the potential risk
and exposure that results from the
blatant failure to follow the same
guidelines you are asking us to
reference
so the district assistant superintendent
somehow obtained or was sent
these photos of the mother and her child
along with other family members and they
were sledding this is this is they're
outside in the snow they're sledding
the horror shock gasp horror
they're outside without masks on the
kids are sledding
and he used that as a reason not to open
the schools
so nothing to be worried about here
right just a school system essentially
spying on families and chastising them
for what they do
on their own time on private property
while schools aren't even open
for business in the first place this is
how desperate the schools are to stay
close no matter what no matter the cost
but even if they open again this is
something else we have to understand
even if they open again that doesn't
necessarily solve the problem here's a
video i want to show you this
a video posted by a teacher of a school
that is set to reopen
and she's showing us what the classroom
is going to look like with all the
coveted regulations and everything
each desk is encased on three sides by
glass the kids will be in glass cages
for class essentially um and this raises
all kinds of problems
as she explains listen i just have a
question for the school board
i'm wondering this is my classroom i
have a rather large classroom compared
to
the other classrooms in our building but
i have 28 desks in here right now if we
go back
five days a week i'll have 30 30 or 32
with the kids coming back from virtual
this is
the middle seat of the back row of my
classroom
this is their view of the board
so i'm just wondering when we ordered
this five million dollars worth of
plexiglas
did we have a classroom of 28 desks set
up
to where school board members
could sit in them and see what this was
really going to be like
because i'm still trying to figure out
how in between my classes am i supposed
to
disinfect how i'm supposed to hear my
students
when they're in the back of the room
wearing a mask behind all this plexiglas
right how will she hear the students
when they try to ask her a question
how will she clean all of these cages
before every class
doesn't this become nothing more than a
a container for
germs you put a bunch of little kids
around glass do you know how smudged and
gross
that's going to be after after one class
are we going to pause for 45 minutes in
between each class
to disinfect everything properly and
most importantly
how is this psychologically healthy for
kids
to go to go from school on a computer to
school in a glass
box and also just as importantly
why is it necessary where is the proof
that any of this will actually make
anyone appreciably safer
and here's yet another question to
ponder why didn't anyone
ever at any point ever
ever even once suggest anything like
this
during flu season nothing like it was
ever suggested
let me read something else dude this is
this is a from a cdc fact sheet
from the cdc comparing and contrasting
the flu and covet
this is what the cdc says okay so
facebook and youtube
don't shut me down for misinformation
this is the cdc's own words
both covet 19 and the flu illness can
result in severe illness and
complications
those at highest risk include older
adults
people with certain underlying
conditions pregnant people
here are the differences the cdc says
the risk of complications for healthy
children
is higher for flu compared to covet 19.
however infants and children with
underlying medical conditions are at
increased risk for both flu and cover
19.
okay higher risk and then it continues
young children are at a young
young children are at a higher risk of
severe illness from flu
higher risk higher now this is not
we already knew this but i want to i
want to emphasize this is what the cdc
itself
says an article on the
american academy of pediatrics website
dated december 29th
says that point zero one percent of
children who've gotten coveted have died
only one point three percent have even
been hospitalized keep in mind
that children are also less likely to
contract and get it
into contracted in the first place so
what is the chance
that a child will bo will both contract
covid and have a serious
possibly fatal reaction you take any
particular
hypothetical child who right now is
healthy and let's say you're sending
them off to school
what are the chances that that child
who's healthy right now
will have a severe possibly fatal
reaction to
covet it's very low
very low that's that's what the numbers
tell us that's what the science tells us
the data is clear
the chances of a child being
hospitalized or killed by the flu
is also relatively small but it's higher
than it is for covet yet we have never
considered
any of these measures for the flu none
of them
now you can come up with all kinds of
excuses and rationalizations for that
right you could say
well the concern is that um kids will
pass covet to adults
yes but they're in a low risk group for
that too a national geographic article
citing a study in iceland says that the
kids are half as likely
to catch and spread covet to catch and
spread coven
you could also say well there's a
there's a more widely available
uh and used flu vaccine than there is
for covet
fine i mean you can come up with other
excuses too but the point is
that we aren't we aren't taking more
precautions for covid than we did for
the flu it's that we took basically
none for the flu while for kovid we've
done
well all of this it's not proportional
it's not reasonable it's not justified
based on the evidence
or on the precedence of our own past
behavior in our own past
approach to these sorts of things
especially where kids are concerned
but here's why it happens right kids are
shut out of school
are put behind glass are scolded for not
wearing masks while they're
playing outside in the snow are forced
into a mental state so desperate that
they're
hanging themselves all of this happens
because our society is one that is
totally and completely run by the
squeaky wheel gets the oil mentality
right never has any society been so
utterly invested
in that particular way of doing things
squeaky wheel gets the oil
and the which means of course the people
who make the most noise who do the most
whining who are the most obnoxious get
their way
that's the way it goes now kids
make plenty of noise and any parent will
tell you they also do plenty of whining
but they don't make the kind of noise
that registers in the public debate
it may register in your eardrums as a
parent at home
but uh it doesn't register in the public
debate in a public debate
it doesn't it's it's not their voice is
not present because they have no
representative they have no special
interest groups they have no union they
have no celebrity spokesman they have no
corporate mouth pieces and because of
that their voice is not hurt at all
in the public debate instead we hear
from the teachers union
from the grown-ups we hear from the
sorts of people who take photos and
videos of other people not wearing masks
and
shame them on the internet or send them
to the superintendent
those are the ones we hear and they get
their way
the kids in their silence are ignored
now let's get to our five headlines
before we get into the five headlines
here uh
feeling carsick is not fun
maybe maybe we could agree if you've
never if you've never experienced that
before you might not realize how
unfun it actually is but people like
myself that deal with that
it is uh it's it can be pretty
disturbing especially when you're
sitting in the back of an uber or a cab
or something or even you've got a friend
driving you and
you're kind of feeling like you might
have to be sick uh and
you're debating whether to have them
pull over to the side of the road that's
gonna be embarrassing
it's just it's not great and that's why
i'm thankful
that relief band is on the market relief
band is here relief band is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraine
hangover morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy so it's not one of
those uh
motion sickness pills that you can take
that are gonna make you drowsy and out
of it for the rest of the day
zero side effects um that's what you get
from relief bin the technology was
originally developed over 20 years ago
in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses relief ben is the only
over-the-counter wearable device that's
been used in hospitals and on oncology
clinics to treat nausea and vomiting
so you know it works uh i use it my my
daughter has used it who also struggles
with uh
motion sickness as well if you want to
be a part of this this new year ensure
that nausea is never the reason to miss
out on life's important moments
right now relief ben has an exclusive
offer just to matt walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code walsh you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30
day money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use promo code walsh for 20
off
day two of our historic winter storm
winter blast i hope you guys are all
staying safe out there
uh you know
the problem is that it seems like 12
times a year
we hear about historic weather events
happening in this country
and after a while it's sort of like
princess bride you think uh
you know i i i don't think that word
means what we think it means because we
we use it so often to describe what
happens
in the weather now i i i think in this
case especially with what's happening in
texas where they've got the you know
sub subfreezing temperatures and snow
and ice and everything uh in parts of
texas where they almost never see this
sort of weather so that okay is is uh
we would call historic what's happening
in nashville right now i don't think
it's historic it's
like snow and freezing rain it's not
common it's not historic though
so this may actually qualify
but this is the problem when you when
you use when everything is dramatic all
the time and sensationalized
and you use the most dramatic adjective
possible to describe
everything then when event when an event
actually occurs
that uh that suits that adjective and
you use it it's lost all meaning
when you call everything historic and
then a real historic event happens
what do you call the real historic event
it's like you need a new word or you
call it historic and it doesn't doesn't
pack the same punch
although i still say uh historic or not
i still
like i've been complaining about this
because partly that's what i do but
uh the fact that here in nashville they
still
plows have not touched the road it's
been two days now
i haven't seen a plow and i'm told i i i
get
people have lived there a lot here a lot
longer than me are telling me that yeah
well they don't
you know it doesn't happen often enough
and to to pay for the plows and to
and take the maintenance and everything
to keep them just to use them once every
few years doesn't make any sense
maybe so maybe so but
for my entitled yankee mentality
i the way that i look at it the way that
i the
way that i operate is if if there's less
than a foot of snow on the ground
i should be able to leave my house and
go for a drive i should be able to do
that with less than a foot of snow
i demand it squeaky wheel like i just
said
um all right number one
yesterday governor cuomo gave a press
conference uh his
favorite pastime of course only this
time he was sort of addressing the
nursing home scandal the scandal wherein
he
sent virus-infected people into nursing
homes and thereby condemned thousands of
people to death
but he puts the blame on a mixture of
people and situations
none of them him of course he blames the
toxic
political environment and quote
conspiracy theories
here he is listen so are you really
saying that
this is sort of the creation of a toxic
political environment that's existed for
several years in this country and in
this state
look is the environment
toxic politically yes was this
happening last year with this toxic
political environment yes
and do i think that's part of the
conspiracy theories that fill the void
yes
and look i understand politics
i was critical of president trump i also
worked with president trump
i get how strong the feelings are on
both sides
but when you're talking about loved ones
dying in nursing homes
uh when you come up with conspiracy
theories or there's disinformation
then the worst thing you can say to
somebody who lost a loved one is
maybe it didn't have to be maybe there
was a government
issue yeah toxic political environment
you mean like um
i don't know like when you cuomo said
that
you wouldn't take the vaccine under
trump's administration
you actually encouraged people to be
skeptical of the vaccine
under trump and then once trump was out
you immediately turned around and
started
scolding the people who were skeptical
of the vaccine that you just told them
to be skeptical of
like that kind of thing it's pretty
toxic i i agree
this really i think all of this um
really amplifies the cringe factor in
this video which is
for whatever reason making the rounds on
social media now but it's from a couple
of months ago
this is what aired if you were wondering
which probably you weren't but
when cuomo won his emmy award a couple
months ago
if you didn't watch that the emmy
ceremony uh because you realize that
you're better off doing literally
anything else with your time this is
what aired
when cuomo was awarded an emmy for his
press conferences this is what they put
on the air
watch to my governor
the governor empire state
andrew cuomo congratulations andrew on
your much-deserved
founders award governor andrew cuomo you
are the man what i was trying to think
of something that i could say to you
that would uh be funny and so i called
your brother chris
who could not understand why you were
getting an emmy since he's the one on
television in the darker stage of the
pandemic
your daily briefings live from new york
gave us hope gave us clarity gave us the
truth and gave us something that we were
not getting from washington
leadership in the midst of this storm
andrew cuomo
became the nation's governor people
across the country tuned into this press
conferences
every day daily i was watching his press
conferences
informing us telling us what to do
i am really going to vomit that is that
is
truly vomitous nauseating
my god and didn't spike lee seem drunk
there
that was a whole if you're listening to
audio maybe you couldn't tell the voices
that was a
compilation of celebrities thanking dear
leader
governor cuomo spike lee being one of me
seemed kind of drunk to me billy joel i
actually felt sorry for you saw him
there he was
he was reading he had this whole speech
it looked like that he was reading
and but they only put him in the
compilation for for for nine seconds
and uh he he read a three a three page
he sat down he's very excited
he wrote he wrote a three-page report uh
on uh
on governor cuomo his whole biography
and everything and he sat there and you
read it
and they only took nine seconds of it so
you feel a little bad for him but those
are all the celebrities
and this is why you can never let the
left
pretend that the cult of personality
around
donald trump was some sort of unique
phenomenon or unique to the right
uh well the left they never have that
never let them pretend that
yeah there is there was and is a cult of
personality around trump i've made it
clear many times i don't think there
should be cults of personality
around any any one period much less any
politician
we shouldn't be fans of politicians we
could be supporters
uh always ready to withdraw that support
you know at the drop of a hat really
that's uh
the the idea of being a fan of a
politician or to be loyal
i don't like that word with politicians
either it's not my job to be loyal to
you as a politician it's your job to be
loyal to me
i'm not i have no loyalty to you i'm
ready to drop you
like a bad habit the minute you get out
of line that's that is the skeptical
really cynical approach that we should
have as americans to our to our elected
leaders
um but cult personality happened on both
on both sides and think about how
quickly
and how unjustifiably this cult of
personality
sprang up around governor cuomo within
within
days uh after a couple of press
conferences
all of a sudden we had this kind of
thing
people left us practically weeping
tears of joy watching this guy give a
press conference
all right um speaking of cults of
personality this is from the daily wire
a new dating trend called
fauci ing fauci ing named after
dr anthony fauci there's another guy
that has a call to personality
the uh the popular medical commentator
white house code of virus advisor
has this this uh trend has singles
dumping partners and potential partners
who refuse to take coven 19 mitigation
seriously
the trend identified by the dating
website plenty of fish has been making
waves on the internet the new york post
reports
and is expected to be a primary issue
for singles in 2021 in an interview with
fauci himself axios tv defined
the practice as quote cutting off a
relationship if you don't think that the
other person is serious enough
about social distancing and taking the
pandemic seriously
um the uh the post notes the term the
term and this definition were coined by
dating at plenty of fish
which included fauchi ing in its annual
list of top dating trends to expect in
the new year
the list released in november also
warned singles singles to watch out for
masquerading or a potential partner only
pretends to care about wearing masks in
kova 19 for the sole purpose of dating
you
and also apocalypsing where you treat
every relationship like it's your last
and get too serious too quick
okay well that last one that's that's
not a new trend
people getting too serious too quick
there's nothing new about that
i don't think we need a new work a new
cute phrase for it um that's
you know people becoming that's called
emotional codependence
it's been a thing it's been a thing in
humanity pretty much forever
uh masquerading though see i see that
phrase and i
what i would think that means and this
is another thing as
i imagine as a single person during the
pandemic that you have to worry
about i would think that masquerading is
uh when an
ugly person wears a mask
and pretends to be not ugly and you meet
someone you don't really know because
they're wearing the mask
i would have thought that's what
masquerading means
but this is the kind of thing i i read
this and i i don't mean to rub it in or
anything but
um ev every day multiple times a day
especially when i read stories like this
i find myself thanking god that i am
married i am
so happy that i'm not single at this
time i i thought that before the
pandemic started but even
but especially now what what do you do
maybe the only silver lining with this
is that i would
i would take it almost um almost like an
anti-fouchying
uh tactic if i was single in dating
kind of a reverse fouching sort of thing
where this is an easy way to weed out
the paranoid lunatics
so if there is anyone out there who you
know wants to wear
you go on a date with someone and uh
you're you're going for a walk or
whatever you're walking to the
restaurant
uh and they want to wear the mask while
you're walking down
the sidewalk now that's that's a good
signal to you
to drop that person don't even bother
but going to dinner
or i suppose that person wouldn't be
going to dinner in the first place
that's the thing if you really if you're
that quote serious about it and paranoid
why would you be dating in the first
place that's what doesn't make any sense
to me
even the paranoid people that's one
thing that's frustrated me about this
from the very beginning even the the
paranoid people they want to have it
both ways
it's like i i mentioned the story um
uh when i went with my family and our
in-laws to a uh
to a christmas lights display a couple
months ago before christmas
this is in indianapolis and we're
outside
and you know we're we're we're distanced
we're socially distant we're not we're
not right up on top of anybody else
we're spaced out from everybody we're
walking outside
and yeah you know i don't have my mask
on
and this this woman walks by and she's
like 10 feet away
and she's holding a cup of like a hot
cider
and she's got the mask on and she starts
yelling at me for not having the mascot
and i think first of all if you're
really that serious about this
that you don't even want to walk outside
without a mask on even when you're 10
feet away from someone what are you
doing at the christmas lights display
why did you come here in the first place
if you're that
worried about it this is this isn't some
essential thing to your life that you
needed to do you could have stayed home
no you came here because you're not that
worried about it
are you and that's the
that's the have your cake and eat it too
attitude that the um
even the paranoid chronovirus people
have all right number three this is a
great tweet from sean penn
it says evangelical leaders should
themselves be impeached by the vatican
if they themselves don't follow nikki
haley's lead and clearly state
they should not have followed satan into
the bowels of hell
but perhaps they're too busy at sex
parties
what makes this a great tweet is first
of all he spells satan
s-a-t-i-n satin so really
they should not have followed satin into
the bowels of hell which i have to say
satin is a higher quality fabric than i
would expect to find in the battles of
hell
but also the whole idea of the vatican
impeaching evangelicals as a catholic i
kind of like the idea
i i sort of like the idea that that i as
a catholic uh
would would or that or at least that
catholic leadership would have the
ability to impeach
protestants i like the idea but it
doesn't quite work that way sean penn i
have to tell you
number four from the sun it says the
pentagon has admitted to holding and
testing wreckage from ufo crashes in a
bombshell freedom of information letter
shared with the sun
researcher anthony bragalia wrote to the
defense intelligence agency
requesting details of all ufo material
which they hold and uh
and results of any tests they've been
carrying out he wrote
this could include physical debris
recovered by personnel of the department
of defense as residue
shot off material or crashed material
from u-a-u-a-p-s
which is unidentified aerial phenomenon
or unidentified flying objects
in the response shared with the sun the
dia released 154 pages
of test results that includes reports on
a mysterious memory metric metal called
nitinol which remembers its original
shape when folded
bergalia said it was a stunning
admission from the u.s government
and the documents reveal that some of
the retrieved debris possesses quote
extraordinary capabilities including the
potential to make things invisible
or even slow down the speed of light
it's a fascinating report and yet again
it's
every other week we get bombshell
ufo news from the government this is
this isn't stuff
from crazy kooky conspiracy theorists or
people on the history channel
ancient aliens people with uh you know
with frizzy hair
talking about how the aliens uh the
pyramids are spaceships or something
this isn't that this is these are
these are official documents from the
government being released
in this case saying hey yeah we have
we've we've uncovered ufo
material and we've tested it it has
invisibility powers
and this stuff comes out and as always
the reaction from the public is
oh ufos aliens yeah whatever big deal
let's find let's see another let's find
another video of a lawyer with a cat
filter
that's that's bigger news which the
catfilter thing was big news don't get
me wrong i you know i was a big fan of
that too as you know
i just don't understand how no one else
seems to care about this
to me this should be headline news this
should be the thing that we're talking
about
but nobody cares i really do wonder as
i've said before
if if the time comes which it may when
aliens
land a ufo invasion
aliens land on earth it's all you know
it's it's a clear we all know that it
happened
i wonder if that would even make the
headlines
number five finally i have to play this
for you and i apologize ahead of time
that i have to play it but i do
uh and here it is
our government's now full of folks who
are extraordinary
but i'm especially impressed by the new
press secretary
she's gained a reputation for her brain
in every session
as well as for the way she likes to use
one pet expression
when you circle back you're no hack
gen sock you're no hack even when
right wingers with a smiling face and
with style and grace that's hajj and
sake circles back
i told you i was sorry but i had to play
it
there's the jen saki song we had the
camilla harris song a couple weeks ago
the only guy who hasn't had a song yet
is is uh
joe biden himself everyone else in
administration is getting his own song
his own tic toc song their own their own
tick tock songs
and joe biden hasn't yet feel a little
bad for him
but there it is there's the jen's hockey
song
when i see this i always think was there
no one for that woman
is there no one in your life who loves
you who would have told you not to do
that
because you know that she if you've got
a song that you've come up with and
you're recording it for tick tock
it's guaranteed that you have performed
this little ditty for other people in
your life before that
and did no one tell you i know it can be
hard it could be a hard thing to say to
someone especially if you care about
hurting people's feelings i don't so i
would i would have no problem
if she if she performed that song for me
i would have no problem saying
that's terrible don't ever do that again
in front of anybody
i would have no problem with that most
people do because they're nicer than me
i get it
but if you really love and care about
someone you got to stop them
before they embarrass themselves on tick
tock all right we're going to go now to
reading the youtube comments here are
some of the comments on the show
yesterday this is from
politics with cooper he says omg matt
who cares about this
when do you actually talk about
important things like our messed up
health care system
our endless wars and our crappy
regulatory system
well i have to tell you politics with
cooper all of those subjects bore me to
death i almost fell asleep just reading
the comment that's how boring
even a reference to those topics
personally to me i find incredibly
boring
if you want to listen to a podcast about
our health care system and regulatory
system
you're free to do that i'm sure there
are podcasts that cover that i don't
talk about that here i don't think that
those are the most
i don't think that they certainly aren't
the most interesting topics to discuss
but i always i love comments like this
from people
getting mad that i'm not talking about
something else i because i don't
understand it there are a lot of
podcasts out there
i mean there are hundreds thousands of
podcasts talk about all different kinds
of subjects
i would never think to tune in to a
podcast
about a subject i'm not interested in
and then get mad at them
for talking about that subject
if i don't want to hear that subject i
could just not listen or listen to a
different podcast
it's like walking in to a a sandwich
shop
and yelling at them for not having
spaghetti you walk into subway and say
what
why don't you guys have spaghetti i want
spaghetti
well then go to olive garden that's
something we do here
william baker says matt i have kid
number two on the way my wife and i are
having long
hours long discussions about what their
first name should be
the idea of then picking a middle name
seems daunting and pointless
after all it would only be necessary if
they need a trendy name
acronym or for their supreme court
appoint appointment
would you be willing to cancel middle
names so we can focus on other things
that actually affect the child thanks i
think you're looking at this the wrong
way william i agree with you that the
the middle name is superfluous and
pointless but um
that also means you can do whatever you
want with it so if this is what i always
say to parents that
uh i if you if you for whatever reason
feel the need
to give your kids some crazy weird ugly
stupid name
then put that in the middle make that
the middle name don't don't don't give
that to your kid as
don't force your your child don't saddle
your child with that as their first name
but with the middle fine you can do
whatever you want with the middle name
get crazy have some fun with it
whatever you want to do so it really
doesn't matter
there's no pressure all of the pressure
is on the first name
so i wouldn't worry about the middle
name at all if you get the first name
wrong though you ruin your kid's life so
pressure's on jared hoagland says matt
you say you're not worried about gun
control
or the gun control push because gun
rights advocates have successfully held
their ground
we're able to hold our ground because we
do worry we recognize that our
government has successfully passed
sweeping assault weapons bans and
invasive gun control bills before and
they'll do it again
the government is full of insatiable
anti-second amendment crusaders
and we barely hold on to our remaining
rights by acting as if each new gun bill
is the end of the second amendment
because it very well might be yeah i
totally agree jerry that's my point
um that this is this is the approach
that
gun rights advocates take where ev any
bill
any measure any policy you like you said
you react as though if this thing goes
through it's the end of the second
amendment
um not willing to give the slightest
inch
and i fully endorse that approach
i think it's the right approach what i'm
saying is
that conservative advocates in other
areas
should look at that as a model i use the
example of
you know in the pro-life fight which as
you know for me that's
that's one of my primary focuses that
should be the approach
you know there there is no pro-abortion
measure no pro-abortion policy that we
will ever support
draw the line we're not going to cross
it
um so i i think that's a model i very
much admire it and i think that it's
it's the proof's in the pudding
okay let's see here um s
hutter says i feel like there's been a
bit of a cultural shift in the
gun control debate actually
i guess this is an auto-correct thing
because the actual comment says
there's been a cultural shift in the tub
control debate
tub control tub control is another
important thing you know people
because adults using bathtubs
really once you're over the age of about
11 you shouldn't be
taking baths at all stewing in your own
filth it's disgusting take a shower be
it be a grown-up
but anyway i think you i think you meant
gun control so there's been a cultural
shift in the gun control debate even a
lot of people on the left have realized
at least in my circles that gun control
hasn't and won't help
they may support background checks and
some restrictions but no but i know a
lot of liberal people who don't support
complete bans
i even know a self-proclaimed socialist
at my work who is super pro second
amendment
which is a bit shocking maybe this is
something that isn't working in the
culture anymore even if they try to pass
federal bans the states can veto it
and since only super extreme people seem
to care hopefully it won't make traction
in the culture either
maybe i'm being hopelessly optimistic
now
um no again i think you're right i think
there has been a cultural shift
um it it at least
it could be temporary but this does not
seem to be the focus
of the left right now gun control
it might be premature to say that
they've surrendered on it i don't know
if they've put up the white flag
necessarily but they seem to have kind
of moved on to other things
because they've gotten they've been
defeated and they figure well this this
isn't working and they've moved on to
other areas
they'll as as jen soccer says they'll
probably circle back though
but for right now again a great example
for conservative for people
conservatives who focus on other issues
so look at that and finally this is from
txrd tv says dear matt what's the proper
flannel to wear when you invite
invite a date over to cannibalistically
consume them
asking for a friend well i guess the
the flannel at that point don't wear
your best flannel
as i guess is what i would say although
my question is
how do you non-cannibalistically consume
someone
answer that on second thought we know
that life insurance is really important
but
before policy genius existed uh think
about how difficult it would have been
to find life insurance you know all the
red tape you have to wade through and
it's just
it could be a very daunting task
probably one of the reasons why a lot of
people didn't get life insurance
before policy genius but we don't have
to worry about that anymore because we
are living in the era of policy genius
a policy genius can help you check off
two big items with ease compare life
insurance rates and
save 50 or more in the process that
means
more cash to put towards the things that
you care about whatever that may be
you're going to keep more cash in your
pocket plus
there's no hassle that's the part that i
like the most the licensed experts work
for you not the insurance company so
they can offer unbiased advice when you
need it
here's how it works first head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out
how much coverage you need and you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam
as well you don't know until you try
once you apply the positive unions team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything they make it that easy for
you that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google uh if you've
been procrastinating with getting life
insurance
stop procrastinating there's no reason
to anymore because it's cheap affordable
easy
to do with policy genius if you're
worried that march is just around the
corner and you've barely gotten anything
done
take a deep breath policy genius will
help you make the most of this short
month
in minutes you could save 50 or more
more by comparing quotes
and feel good knowing that your loved
ones will be taken care of if anything
should happen to you go to
policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
also as i'm sure you know actress gina
carino has been making her way through
the news cycle recently
uh she was the star of a hit disney plus
show the mandalorian and was dropped
from the series you heard all about this
story as
the hollywood the woke mob the hollywood
mob is going after any conservatives and
that's why they got rid of her
they come up with their own excuses but
that's the real reason that we all know
at one point in time that would be the
end of the story
the woke mob tosses someone to the curb
and that's it that's the last you hear
should say uh developing producing and
starring in an upcoming film that would
be released exclusively to daily wire
members
we've all said it you know conservatives
need to do more than complain and
critique as much as i enjoy doing both
of those things
we need to stop running away from the
culture we need to be creators and
influencers
that challenge the leftist narrative in
hollywood challenge it directly
and that's what this is all about disney
plus has
eight billion dollars to spend per year
we have you
okay so join us today in the fight to
take back our culture go to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code gina that's
g-i-n-a to get 25
off your membership today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
you know often on the daily cancellation
i'm going out on a limb on my own to
cancel somebody bravely canceling what
nobody has canceled before but today is
a somewhat rare occasion where i will
join
a pre-existing cancel mob to cancel
uh someone by the name of james charles
james charles is a famous youtuber known
for
uh wearing makeup a while ago he became
a cover girl
even though he's not a girl and
this fact that he's not a girl is
something that he apparently needs to be
reminded of
charles is as the media tells me facing
backlash
for a youtube stunt where he experienced
pregnancy for a day
experienced pregnancy for a day and by
experienced pregnancy i mean that he
wore a prosthetic belly
and took some nude pregnancy photos and
that's it
that was the essentially the extent of
his pregnancy experience
because i know you really want to see it
here it is
watch all of our close friends are all
in a group chat together and a few days
ago we were all joking around with her
and she came back at us and said i bet
you could not last
24 hours of being pregnant and i thought
to myself okay
challenge accepted so for today's
youtube video laura is going to join us
and we're going to be doing a ton of
different challenges and tasks to really
see if i am
strong enough to experience what it's
actually like being pregnant for 24
hours straight let's get started
you're squishing the baby
oh a little sideways tactic that was
insane you definitely want your knees
okay i'm a professional dog clearly
since i got pregnant
subtle yeah like that now like james
charles
i am not a girl so like james charles i
don't
know what pregnancy is like but i'm
pretty sure
after having watched my wife go through
it several times that it involves more
than having to sit sideways at the table
so your stomach doesn't
get in the way there are all kinds of
psychological emotional
hormonal aspects to the experience that
cannot be
replicated also bladder related aspects
i'm told so if you really want to give
pregnancy simulation a shot
you should at least once pee yourself
from
sitting down too fast or however it
works
the backlash charles experiencing comes
from people claiming that he's
minimizing pregnancy and making a joke
out of it
i agree that he's doing that um and but
i think the canceling should go further
because this is not
just minimizing making a joke out of
this is appropriation
and it is appropriation far more
degrading and reductive
than say a white person wearing a native
american head dress for halloween
so he should receive a consequence at
least as harsh as
the one we would dole out for the person
on halloween wearing that costume
the rules should be applied consistently
i am a firm believer that the left
should be required to live by its own
standards
even if i don't agree with the standards
these are your standards
you should have to live by them in fact
i'm the one who shouldn't have to
you you should have to not me
so that's why when it comes to the left
standards i will
i will passionately defend any
conservative against the left's
standards
but i will take those standards and
passionately argue that people on the
left should have to live by them and
that doesn't make it a double standard
for me no
because again they're not our standards
they're yours
you live by them i don't care what you
think about appropriation or anything
else
but you should care what you think
you're the one who thinks it
now um in this case though
it really is appropriation okay and it's
part of a larger cultural trend wherein
men are claiming womanhood for
themselves turning womanhood into a
costume they can wear
claiming female spaces for their own
taking what rightfully belongs to women
in fact
the only kind of identity that is
actually being appropriated in this
culture
is womanhood it's not possible actually
to appropriate a culture that doesn't
exist
cultures are fluid cultures are
ever-changing culture is a human
construction
culture is always influenced and always
always influencing others that's the
nature of culture it cannot be
taken it can't be stolen somebody
participating in your culture is not at
all
infringing on your ability to experience
your own culture for yourself
in its fullness cultural appropriation
doesn't exist
yet it's the appropriation that we hear
the most about female appropriation
does exist yet we hear almost nothing
about it
despite what we're told sex is not fluid
it is not a construct it is not a
societal invention unlike culture
what's more a man participating in
womanhood is
depriving women of their ability to
experience it in its fullness
for example a man who participates in
female sports is effectively taking
female sports
away from females and on a deeper level
girls are raised in the belief that
their identity their femininity their
girl hood is mutable
changeable superficial i ask the famous
question all the time what is a woman
well we live in a culture that cannot
answer that question therefore girls are
brought up in this culture
deprived of an identity that has meaning
deprived of a definable identity
that's the consequence of female
appropriation it's serious it's real
everything the left says about cultural
appropriation applies here
it doesn't apply there but it applies
here
james charles is a womanhood
appropriator of long standing
this is by far not his first foray into
cheapening womanhood degrading it
using it like a toy and for that he's
cancelled
he should be canceled just as much as
any cultural appropriator ever has been
and more much more
instead he'll get some mean internet
comments and then continue along with
his life
unimpeded corporate sponsors still
intact
corporate sponsors by the way that
should be going to women
real women not a guy who pretends to be
for clicks and clout
so james charles is officially
cancelled by me anyway
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
a democrat congressman calls for a
commission to punish conservatives a
very prominent liberal writer admits
that there's a conservative blacklist
in hollywood and global warming
alarmists
cause a bunch of texans to freeze check
it out on the michael knowles show